c'était l'époque d'internet de l'époque
à l'époque il n'y avait pas à l'époque
où googleliser pas on lit causé sur les
causses on se donnait encore sur msn
pour s'envoyer des wizz les téléphones
n'avait pas de 4g c'est une et téléphone
pour téléphoner et faire de la muscu
c'est
l'époque des connexions pour y est il y
avait des boules dans nos souris ils
ignorent
martin 2
heureux de la nuit
d'autres mecs le tout couplé joan jett
et ce car
sur voile
r on avait des pseudos mais pas de photo
de profil pour se rencontrer en vrai
c'était difficile donc donovan si c'est
toi c'est ça c'est moi et toi t'es bon
base blonde du 7 5
oui mon corps tu fais tes parents ne
pouvez pas téléphoner normal raccroche
son internet deezer ni spotify c'est le
ton de we know la moyenne en fait où ils
enquêtent shiraz à
casa télécharger un film en trois
semaines sans règle qu'une fois sur deux
on tombait sur avec j'avais pas qui est
cette semaine à estoril hyper bien fait
mais moi vieillesse l'époque on avait
des disquettes on allait sur le net avec
netscape occupait pas de
wikipedia
on
consul d encarta à
[Musique]
mais ce n'était pas très connu et en
particulier par les profs du bail
et on pouvait copier coller sans se
faire coller norman c'est incroyable de
3 vous êtes passé à 20 sur 20 ben moi
j'aime vraiment tout ce qui est
mésopotamie mérovingienne sa maman mon
délire quoi c'est incroyable bravo je
suis fier de vous normal c'est un truc
de ouf monga sûr c'est une époque où
graver des cd et des cd vierges
un peu comme un ver
ja.b paillot pas neuf hynix vidéo weeks
after les sites pour adultes être été un
peu dur
d
avec laconique sur le chargement été si
long que bien souvent que tu fais sur
ingénieurs des téléphones fixes au petit
déjeuner
manger et qui m'aiment pas plus belle
certains se souviennent de ibada toulon
pourrait s'installer but est d'avoir une
page my en effet tous habitent ce mec
n'avait qu'une eux seuls taux de lui eh
bah ouais bah tu en étais pas prêt à
bosser bon c'est pas grave peu comme si
tu allais garder cette photo toute ta
vie c'est clair l'époque d'internet
internet avec hugo commencer les vidéos
là les potes
oui avec un vrai must have en qui la
prolonge atypique et bien sûr tavini je
veux même pas de la cité
je n'ai pas de paname
marly gomont
lester la belle époque ça madame je me
rappelle est aussi lui
didier digard deux heures départ mots à
nos jeunes vers 10h valley sur la louve
away ou club internet et wyeth wifi que
des modems 56k
on s'envoyait palestine chan
ckx nous montrer le bit aurait à
l'échoppé jo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu veux me voir sur scène mais pas de
souci vient voir mon spectacle norman
sur scène que je joue actuellement dans
toute la france
et je vois aussi à paris au palace à
partir du 15 octobre 2015 pour prendre
directement ta place eh bien tu cliques
sur le petit lien de la description tout
simplement tu verras je suis hyper
marrant c'est abusé